hi guys I'm John boyega from Star Wars
The Lost Jedi I'll be going undercover
on the Internet
this is actually me let's do this
Twitter John boyega for real can we just
sit next to you at the Star Wars
premiere so we can watch you react to it
the Emma's I'm sitting next to my
parents and unfortunately I will never
give up their seats but you will hear me
that you will hear my voice from facade
facade Oh facade in a Nigerian boy from
fist I are excited for Star Wars because
my twin brother at Jamaica do we look
alike skip that one John boyega did you
get to keep a version of clothes jacket
for your personal wardrobe no but I am
gonna make sure I do that because I've
been asked that so many times but thank
you for that question
we've got more Twitter hi John boyega
you seem to have a good taste in food
you mind joining me for dinner at a
restaurant of your choice this Friday
evening I'm married to Jesus I can't a
concept Idris Elba as headstock Octavia
Spencer as Catelyn Tully John boyega
as Rob stock chosen Jacobs as brand
stock I'm with it you give me a script
I'll do it I'll sign up for sure John
Vega do you think Rey and Finn would
have Netflix and chill dates
I feel me and Ray will go to the
carnival and break it up
yeah my poor ax it's actually me how did
John boyega and Daisy really get
selected for Star Wars what did they
have to go through to finally land their
respective roles for me it started from
a call from my agent and said that
there's this secretive movie out there
and they want to see for it and then it
led to eight months of just back-to-back
auditions of working out and waiting for
this rod tip off and they eventually did
so and thankful for that
why does Ray have an English accent and
Finn have an American one in the force
awakens given that they're both British
actors is it a clue to their origin or
their parentage because acting means you
play roles that are not necessarily you
so you don't have to play an English
person in the movie just because you're
English I'm here online answering these
questions if they tuned what type of
English accent does John boyega have I'm
from southeast London ac15 Peckham I
have a South accent
Yahoo Answers is John boyega the black
Hugh Laurie in that they both do such
convincing American accent and they
surprised people by being British it's
interesting because some people still
think I'm African American
which is strange but that's what we do
acting what does Stormtroopers or clone
troopers see through their helmets
absolutely nothing that's why they can't
shoot straight I am the one that figured
it out if I take off my helmet then I
can shoot straight
you only stormtrooper to do it ready
guys I know you don't believe it but
it's actually me it's Finn Lando's son I
mean it could be possible right I don't
know I don't know because we'd let John
as a young kid meeting Sir Ian McKellen
I was part of a theatre group called
Peckham at the time and one day they
took us to the Shakespearean Globe
Theatre and I met Ian McKellen for the
first time I actually met him in real
life I think I was like 12 or 13
Wikipedia birdie life boy Jaeger was
born in Peckham that was it
the South London two British Nigerian
parents Abigail me a boy during that
work on that the social worker but she
wasn't and Samson and Vega a Pentecostal
minister correct
his first role was a leopard in a play
his primary school correct
and John boyega is extremely handsome
via his DNA it's embedded and he is
extremely charming and was always
charming and will be forever Amen posted
[Music]